foreign
[Music]
disaster is going to require many months
if not years for the recovery so I think
governments and the internal the
coordination with the two authorities an
international organizations that can
also support by ensuring proper
coordination not duplication ensuring
that the the distribution of the work
not only geographically but also in the
areas of expertise is going to be
crucially needed the first thing is
access especially in Syria is becoming
challenging challenging in areas that
have been badly affected
and this represents a problem and this
is access related to the impact of the
record in terms of accessing to rural
areas for example is not an easy thing
to achieve to the urban cities is is
much easier of course similarly in the
case of of turkey and Syria the other
big challenge is the winter the winter
represents an additional problem that we
need to overcome in terms of the current
capacities that are in place to
guarantee a proper shelter and that the
communities that normally are the
hardest to reach also are able to to be
supported
the bridge
uh
[Music]